In this episode, I wanted to walk you through the profitability formula.
You see, many people think they're profitable or maybe even think they're un
profitable.
And I want to kind of help you understand what does profitability even mean,
right?
Profitability and kind of the one thing that you can really bring it down to is
your profit factor.
Now, do we have profit factor in this report?
We do not, which is fine.
It's on your dashboard anyway, but we're going to be strictly looking at
reports.
So we're going to be looking at the reports of the couple of months traded when
I was in an evaluation phase one and phase two.
The most important data that you need to be understanding is as follows.
So your average winning trades, that's an important data point we need to be
tracking.
If you take all of the trades that I win and then you divide them by the amount
of winning trades that were,
the average winning trade netted me $3,922.
That was my average win.
My average loss was $1,621.
Now, why are these two numbers so important?
In and of themselves, they aren't just that important, but they do give you an
insight into your profitability.
For example, let's say my average winning trade was $3,922 and my average
losing trade was $1,621.
Let's say that was the only data we had, one may look at that and think that's
amazing.
That's great, right?
But not necessarily because without understanding how many trades we took,
how many of those trades were winners and how many of those trades were losers.
This is data that is misleading because you could technically have a $10,000
average winning trade and only a $1,000 average losing trade.
But if you take 100 trades and you only win nine of them, then you are unprof
itable.
The same goes, to be honest with you, if let's say this was $4,000 and let's
say this was $4,000,
that on paper would look like a break-even trader.
But if you took 100 trades and you won 80 of those trades and lost just 20 of
them,
that would be a profitable trader.
So these numbers, many people get obsessed with P&L, right? How much did I make
? How much did I lose? All that good stuff.
But here's the profitability formula.
Profitability is you take your average winning trade and then you also need to
take your average losing trade.
But then we need to understand our win rate.
The way we can understand our win rate is we can go and look at, we had a total
number of trades.
Our total trades were $52, so let me just get a calculator.
So we took 52 trades, right? That's information that we need to know.
But here we took 14 break-even trades.
So we actually want to remove those trades because we didn't win anything or we
didn't gain anything.
So we want to remove those trades.
And so actually we have 38 trades that resulted in a win or a loss directly.
Now, if 30 out of those 38 trades will lose us and my average losing trade was
$1,621,
well, I would have lost, I don't know what is that, like over $50,000, right?
So if 30 of those 38 trades were losers, that would be approximately just under
$50,000.
And then the other eight of them were winners that would have netted me
approximately $31,000.
And so I would actually be net unprofitable by around $18,000.
It's not enough to win more than you lose, which is what a lot of people say.
When I win, I win more. When I lose, I lose less.
Like, yeah, cool, that's great. But how often do you win and how often do you
lose?
And other people, their problem is that they will look at this, right?
They might see 52 trades and they might see 42 winners and let's say 10 losers.
Amazing, sounds great.
But if when you win, you're only making $500 and when you lose, you're losing $
3,000, then it's not great.
So it's the combination of those numbers.
And this is the thing because people look at them individually.
They come and they say, I want a high win rate.
Okay, why do you want a high win rate?
Because I just want to win more trades because if I win more trades, I'll make
more money.
Maybe, but maybe not.
So let's take a look at this 52 total trades.
We're going to exclude the 14 that leads with 38.
We took 38 trades in total, right?
That's our total number of trades that were either winners or losers, which is
what matters to us.
16 of them were winners.
22 of them were losers.
So I lost more trades than I would.
Does that mean I'm a bad trader?
Well, no, because when I won, I actually made 3,922.
So for every trade that I won, I won this amount.
And for every trade that I lost, I lost 16,021.
You need these numbers together.
And that is ultimately going to give you your profitability formula.
And so if we go and figure out what our actual profit factor is, which isn't
logged in here.
So your profit factor essentially represents for every $1 that you lose, how
many dollars do you win?
So anything over one is profitable.
So I need to figure out for every $1 that I lose, how many dollars do I win?
And the way you do that is you understand that we took 38 trades, we won 16, we
lost 22, right?
So what I need to do here, I need to understand what is this number?
16 times 3922 is $62,752.
That's how much I won in total.
But I also lost.
And so in total, I lost 35,600 and 62.
So I lost more trades than I won, but I made $62,000 in total and I lost $35,
000 in total.
Give me a net profit of $27,090.
So that's how much money I made with all of these trades.
Now what we want to do, we need to understand our overall profit factor.
So we need to take this right, 62, 752 because that's how much we won in total,
so 62, 752.
We need to divide our profit by our loss.
So if I divide my profit, which is 62,752 by the loss that I took, which was 35
,662,
that gives me a 1.759 and we can get into the kind of smaller details that
right there.
And you can kind of just round that up and remove that and just make this a six
.
So we can probably conclude that there's a 1.76 is my profit factor.
Meaning for every $1 that I lose, I win $1.76.
Now that's not bad.
It could be better than that.
The higher the number, the better the overall trading performance and system,
obviously.
But that's really how you understand whether you're profitable or not.
Many people get lost in this idea of what do I win when I win?
What do I lose when I lose?
Or they just focus on, okay, well, how many trades did I win?
And how many trades did I lose?
And it's like you have to take these individual data points and put them
together to understand what actually makes sense.
So the key data points, again, just to recap that you want to be looking at,
right?
If I can just quickly get rid of all of this.
So I want to be looking at my average winner versus my average loser.
How much do I win on average, how much do I lose on average, how you calculate
this, which trades that I will do for you.
But you need to still understand how to read the data.
How to calculate this is you take the total dollar gain.
So the total dollar you made and then divide that by the total amount of
winning trades you took.
And that's going to give you your average winning trade.
The same for your average losing trade.
How much did you lose in total and then divide that by the amount of losing
trades that you took?
That's going to give you average losing trade in dollars.
You also need to understand your win rate.
So how you calculate your win rate is you want to take the total number of
trades.
So total trades minus breakevens.
That's going to give us our total effective trades.
So the total amount of trades that were either winners or losers, right?
So we need to take this number, which in this case is 38.
And then we need to understand our average winning trades was 16.
So you want to take the total number of winning trades, which is 16 and then
divide that amount
by the total effective trades.
So all trades minus breakeven, you want to divide that and then times by 100 to
get your percentage.
So we have 16 winners.
We have 38 total impactful trades that gives us 0.42 times by 100.
That gives us a 42.1% win rate, meaning the total amount of winning trades
relative to the total amount of trades
that either made money or lost money, 42% of them were winning trades.
So that's a very important piece of data.
So we understand that we have a win rate of 42.1%.
I believe it was that's our win rate.
Awesome.
And we understand that our profit factor was 1.76.
I want to say that's our profit factor.
Very, very important.
So we have our win rate is 42.1% our profit factor is 1.76.
We also want to understand our average risk to reward.
So our average risk to reward and our average risk to reward is going to pretty
much be our average wins divided
by our average losses.
Very simple.
So every time we lose how much we lose, every time we win, how much we win.
We win an average 3922.
We lose an average 1621.
So 3922 divided by 1621.
That's going to give us 2.42.
That's my average risk to reward.
Those are the data points that you want.
You want to understand what percentage of your total effective trades do you
win?
What is your average risk to reward?
That's going to give you your profit factor.
And then that ultimately gives you a grasp on your trading, right?
Those are your three most important KPIs.
You want to understand your win rate, your average risk to reward because those
two numbers together are what
are going to give you the sense of profitability only with those numbers
together because it's all well
and good having an average risk to reward of one to five.
But if your win rate from that one to five is only 15%, well, your profit
factor is going to be less than one,
which indicates you are an unprofitable trader.
Same can be true, even if you have a high win rate.
If you have a 70% win rate sounds amazing in theory, anything less than let's
say 0.5.
You win half of what you your risk, which by the way, the reason I'm explaining
this is because how many people
that I see online that brag about their win rate or their win tricks.
I haven't lost a trade in eight weeks and I've taken 50 trades and I haven't
lost any.
It's like, yeah, but your average risk reward is like 0.2.
Like do you understand?
Like it's the data points in and of themselves are irrelevant.
Like if you have a 0.2 average risk reward, even with a 70% win rate, you are
unprofitable long term.
You're going to go on some amazing win streaks.
But trying to do it consistently over extended periods of time, you will lose
money.
And so it looks great in the meantime.
I haven't lost a single trade in 25 trades.
I haven't lost any trades in eight weeks.
Okay, cool.
You like you have an 80% win rate, but your average is towards 0.1.
I don't care about vanity metrics.
I don't care about an average win rate of a one to 10 that you can show only
every three weeks
because it was just after taking loss after loss after loss after loss after
loss.
And then you finally show that one one to 10 years reward, which so many of
these gurus online are doing.
So please, you need to understand what actually is profitable trading from a
data perspective.
What KPIs actually indicate whether you are on the right track or whether you
are not.
And it's also important to understand this stuff because just relying on your P
and L,
which obviously gives you an indicator, but you can have drawdown periods,
right?
Like you can have times you can have weeks, you can have months where maybe you
lose money.
And maybe you break even that doesn't mean you're a bad trader.
You're just going through a dry patch.
You need to just understand the numbers of your edge and always make sure that
they make sense.
And then you can optimize because that's where the optimization comes in.
It's like you see those things, right?
Let's say you have a 42% win rate and let's say your average are in the case of
this challenge.
I think it was 2.4.
We just said that was the data.
Now I can come in and optimize because I can look at the data and understand if
I go run a back test on the system.
I can understand the ideal average.
More armable and then I can start increasing my average reward.
I can look at ways to bring that 2.4 higher ever use a fixed a profit.
There's all these different theories that you could then go away and use to
look at increasing that number or maybe you have too low of a win rate.
And so you're able to go back through your data and go and analyze the losses
and try to find patterns with certain setups.
For example, every time I take a trade in New York session, when there's
already been a winning trade in London session,
my win rate of that specific setup is 20%.
But it also accounts for 35% of the trades that I've taken.
So if I remove all of those trades, it automatically brings up my win rate.
Just by avoiding those trades, I'm able to bring my win rate higher.
This is where you can start getting an experimentative.
But if you don't have this data, if you don't have these important KPIs,
then you don't really know what to do.
And at the same time, you can be overwhelmed because there's so much data that
you can collect.
But you need to understand what's the most important data.
And so I just wanted to make this to make you understand the profitability
formula.
And the profitability formula is what you want to be looking at is what's your
profit factor.
Anything over one is good.
Anything under one is bad.
The higher the better and you want to optimize for bringing that profit factor
as high as possible.
And the way you want to be looking at that is your average risk reward and your
win rate.
Very, very important that you want to be understanding those.
You also want to be factoring in as well guys, your commissions fees or swaps.
So if you have commissions, if you have fees, if you have swaps on your
positions,
you want to make sure that you're taking notes of them and make sure you're
adding them
because that is a part of your liability.
If these are super close, let's say my average winning trade is $1,100.
My average losing trade is $1,000, but my win rate is 50%.
So on paper, I win half of my trades.
But when I win 1,100, when I lose, I lose 1,000.
That looks great on paper.
But now all of a sudden I'm taking five trades a day and I'm getting
commissions on how many lots that I trade.
And because I'm an intraday trader, I'm trading large lot sizes.
So I'm getting commissions on lots.
Sometimes I'm holding trades overnight and then incurring swaps.
And now all of a sudden your average fee per trade is all of a sudden, let's
say $101.
And so you factor that in.
Well, now all of a sudden you actually have an unprofitable system.
So you want to be factoring in your commissions, fees and swaps as well.
I don't incur any commissions, fees or swaps on the prop firm that I use on
personal accounts.
That is something that I do incur.
So you want to make sure that you always understand in your fees as well and
understanding how to factor them in.
That's when you can start really understand your data, but we'll stick for here
for now.
And we'll just look at just the profitability formula because I wanted to make
sure that these are the most important numbers you have to understand.
And these are the most important numbers that you want to be optimizing around.
You want to be looking at ways to increase your win rate or your average risk
reward dependent.
And here's another thing as well, by the way, last point is sometimes you may
be able to increase your average risk reward at the detriment of your win rate.
That's pretty common.
The higher risk reward, usually the lower the win rate, the higher the win rate
, usually the lower the risk reward.
So you want to find the generous sweet spot where you're getting the most from
each.
You want to be optimizing so that the risk to reward and the win rate are the
best that you can get combined with each other.
Right.
So hopefully that makes sense.
Well, you don't want to go crazy on risk to reward and then completely wipe out
your win rate because it also you have to think about draw down periods.
You have to think about psychology like I'll give you an example.
When I first started trading, the reason that you can see I'm so passionate
about these guys that show these crazy trades is because everyone out there
will show in these ridiculous trades.
And I thought that, you know, those are the types of trades I had to take.
I was always getting in trades.
And even when I was in a winning position and that trade would run nicely, one
to three, one to five, I'm trying to hold this trade for a one to 15.
And I'm time after time after time, one to seven back to break, even one to
five back to break, even one to eight back to break, even my win rate was super
low.
My average hour was massive because when I won, I won huge, but my win rate was
so bad.
It made it so difficult psychologically because every trade I would take, I
would know that there's a much higher chance that I lose this trade than that I
win.
And so it was for the optimization of going, you know what, so many of these
trades have run in one to three, one to five, one to seven, and then coming
back at break, even then you start optimizing.
Like, okay, well, I'm going to sacrifice my average risk to reward, but bring
my win rate up, at least.
That's when you start getting into playing and data experiment and figuring out
what works best for your personality.
That is the profitability formula, those are the numbers you have to be looking
at if you want to understand whether you or your edge is actually profitable.